- [Voiceover] A circle in
the xy-plane has a diameter
with endpoints at eight, comma, 10
and negative two, comma, zero.
Which of the following is
the center of the circle?
So let's think about it.
If you have some circle in the xy-plane,
so this is my best attempt
at drawing a circle,
and if you had two end
points of a diameter,
so let's say
that this is a diameter
right over here.
It looks something like this.
So let's say that's our
diameter right over there
and that this point was the
point negative two, comma, zero,
and this was the point eight, comma, 10.
What would be the coordinates
of the center of the circle?
Well the coordinates of
the center of the circle
is going to be the midpoint
of these two end points
of a diameter.
In fact the center of the
circle is always going to be
the midpoint of the two
ends points of the center
of a diameter.
If the diameter was this right over here,
if the diameter was this over here,
then once again the center
of the circle is a midpoint
of that point, and that
point right over there.
So to answer this question,
we just have to find
the midpoint of this point and
this point right over there.
And to find a midpoint, we
just have to find the average
of the x coordinates and the
average of the y coordinates.
So let's see this is going
to be eight, the x coordinate
the average of eight and
negative two is eight
plus negative two,
plus negative two over two,
and the average of 10 and
zero, we know that's five,
but we could say that's
10 plus zero over two.
And let's see eight plus
negative two is six,
divided by two is three and then
10 divided by two is five.
Three, comma, five.
And we see it right over there.